my Oregon Duck guard Sabrina I&S cue the
John Wooden Award winner I got a Jersey
sent to me Sabrina it's it's yours but I
don't know if it's actually your so I I
feel bad if somebody sent me the Jersey
it showed up in the mail so do you know
how I got this oh I don't know I yeah
just take credit for it says extra large
so I'm guessing that that it's gonna fit
me that's the reason why I was sent to
me but it's pretty cool that Nike did
this did you have to go to Nike and say
you know why aren't we selling my
jerseys I mean I I don't know if it was
in the works or not but I was getting
people asking me non-stop about the
jerseys and so I had tweeted kind of
just asking like hey not even for me but
just for other people just because I'm
getting asked all the time and then the
jerseys are out and selling so it is
pretty cool that's great what's your
trophy room look like I don't really
have one to be honest I usually like
give them away or keep them at school
somewhere just because I don't have room
for them so they're kind of all over the
place i I don't really hold on to them
what is the one piece of memorabilia
that you have sports memorabilia that
you treasure I have to keep jerseys so I
have like a lot of jerseys from when I
was playing when I was younger my USA
basketball jerseys my high school
jerseys College jerseys so I think
jerseys are the ones that I'll hold on
to what about pro players did you
collect jerseys from them no I didn't
collectors I mean I have jerseys
I have Klay Thompson's Jersey so I have
some jerseys there I mean a bunch of
pictures banners off all that stuff and
how did you form the relationship with
Kobe Bryant we became friends a few
years ago when he brought his daughter
to our game at USC
and then but that's got to be pretty
surreal where you're going okay there's
Kobe okay he's walking over here can't
be cool under how did you react it was
really cool I mean it's it's always it's
always humbling and you I got goose
bumps and I was like oh my gosh is that
Kobe and our coaches knew but they
didn't they didn't tell us so it really
was like a surprise to see him and to
just like be able to see him in person
was crazy and look I loved watching you
play certainly with your ability to be a
you know triple-double machine there the
poise you showed at Kobe's memorial far
outweigh anything that you did on the
basketball floor you were I don't know
how nervous you were you were
unbelievable that day
thank you I was very nervous before and
after I think just seeing how many
people were there and obviously all the
emotions that were filled with being
there was tough but I think once I
started and finally got up there and
started speaking I didn't really think
about it too much but I definitely was
very nervous
sabrina is Q the former Oregon Duck
guard and best college basketball player
in the country the last two years what's
it been like last month you know this
since they decided they weren't going to
play the tournament what have you done I
can get into and go to that I worked out
with before and then just lifting and
doing yoga reading still in school so
just trying to find things to stay busy
and stay sharp Liberty the New York
Liberty had the number one overall pick
Sam right have you already started
looking at what it cost to live in New
York favorite player growing up
uh Steph berry and now have you shot
with him yeah we worked out we're
actually really close friends now so
it's kind of uh it's kind of cool to see
the relationship grow what do you do
better than Steph Curry but you see that
range Sabrina like you know we watch on
TV but that's I mean he invented that
you can say that I mean Steph has had a
bigger impact on the game than almost
anyone in the history of the sport
because he allowed everybody who is
smaller to think that they can play you
don't have to be physical
I mean Steph Curry's impact on the game
cannot be understated no it can't don't
see that and don't value that don't
really understand the impact that you've
had on the sport I mean you walk in any
gym and there's there's little kids
shooting from half-court they're
shooting
you know shots like Steph and it's
evolved the game I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if the three-point line gets
moved back you know moving forward and
it's because of him and his ability so
it's been cool to see that if you didn't
play basketball on what would you be
doing probably going to work going to
going to college living living a life
what's your major if I wasn't playing
basketball what you know what's your
major
society wait what is it crime law just
like my mom yeah yeah you want to be a
police officer
CSI it's great to have you on you should
be very proud of what you did and I
meant what I said about what you know to
stand up there at Kobe's tribute that
that memorial and I went I couldn't have
done it and I'd do this for a living
couldn't have done it but you're a
special player and certainly a special
person I wish you luck in the WNBA and
with the New York Liberty
thank you so much for having me and for
the opportunity I appreciate it
that's a Sabrina I ask you the Oregon
two-time Wooden Award winner